welcome to an edition of end games for
tournament players
I am your co-host or sub host whatever
you want to call me Mike comer filling
in for the legendary Yasser ceramide all
right tonight we're gonna be going over
working pulling in games where White has
an extra pass on so it should be pretty
easy right okay so first things first
where do you think we want to get our
rook in front of the pawn behind the
pawn or on the side anymore
behind the pawn right you want to get
behind the pawn so you want to get
behind the pawn if you can't get behind
the pond then on the side the last place
you want to be as we'll see is in front
that's called the dumb rook okay and you
don't want a dumb Rock okay so so it's
real easy in this position what to do
you just get behind the pawn first you
offer hey you want to trade and you're
like nope because if black would trade
here it would be a very easy endgame to
win for white so he's like I'm gonna get
in front of the pawn so then the rook
gets behind it to protect it and so now
White has is a his ideal position here
and so now he's going to try to get his
King over to help block the enemy pawn
here so King up hang up so who thinks
this is not going to be the easiest
thing in the world for white to do all
right
little did you know that the player
playing black is me so it's not gonna be
so easy here okay so so first you throw
I want to check so now King up and over
rook to a3 didn't really make any prize
with that move so now I'm right in front
of the pond I'm stopping this pawn from
getting any further down my throat here
okay so check a king up alright so what
did he just do
he had his dream position the rook
behind the pawn and then he's like well
that's not working for me so I'll just
put it to the side
all right he's not gonna like what
happens and a couple moves from now
alright so rook back so I can start
delivering to the checks I don't have to
worry about him playing a five anymore
right because I'll just take it big
moves
alright so now brick moves it's a king
so now Shaq what's the only move here
that doesn't lose the rook yeah block
with the rook excellent alright good so
he's got to block it and now I play here
so now is a rook here a good move to
protect the a pawn
no girls I just take it right for
nothing all right so good so he plays
King over so now I'm watching on this
pawn okay but now he's got the check and
I came back so now the Kings in in prime
situations to block the enemy pawn so
now he attacks me so I attack his pawn
so he protects it and so now he's kind
of solidified over here but that Willy
wasn't the goal was it he wanted to get
this pawn to become a queen so now h6
so what do you think blacks trying to do
with this move h6 yes
got to think deeper than that yes James
IV yeah now I got the poem majority and
so now what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
create my old passport
well your punch just it hasn't even
moved sense move one at this thing right
but you'll see my pawns are moving so
now he finally gets the idea hey man I
need to get my opponent moving with
check so King up King up again just
check the King out of there alright and
now capture capture so now I have a
passed pawn so now I'm gonna I'm gonna
try to win this pawn here and so he
plays his pawn up that doesn't really do
much so I'm kind of going come and get
it okay
so now he tries to uh to get a check the
checkmate going right all right so rook
takes King up check King up
so now it should black play uh well
maybe you should so there's a big big
discrepancy should he do it or net a lot
of people are saying don't do it it's a
trap others people are saying they're
going crazy okay so is this checkmate no
black and there's a Rick play rook check
take
some people are saying yes some people
are the correct the correct answer in
this position is hey let me calculate it
let me see if I should take it right so
so so who wants to say All Whites gonna
draw no problem I'm gonna lose but I'm
gonna do it anyway or who wants to just
say I've got well I want to calculate
who wants to calculate who wants to just
go for it all right
the Aged spawn right you're good oh now
you're in a lot of trouble mister
obviously I'm not gonna play Age 3 here
or else you know he catches me okay and
so he can never take this pawn right
this is endgame 101 or else you can't do
it so you got it you got to calculate in
the endgame because one wrong move
you're toast okay
so unfortunately the player playing
black did take here and say he just say
I'm gonna take it and it's gonna be
Czech and it's gonna be so cool but he's
got this check here take take
and now after f5 see if Claudio can
figure out a mate and 27 here for white
can you do it Claudio yeah for white
apparently this was a huge error it
allows white to checkmate black in 27
moves but you can't find it so so he's
just like I'm just gonna win the pawn
and win the game
well draw the game obviously draw okay
not the result white was expecting when
he's up a pawn that's why you have to
get a plan a good plan and stick to it
so his plan initially was perfect right
I'm going to get my rook behind the pawn
I'm gonna bring my king up here and then
I'm gonna push my pawn instead he's like
I want to check them then I'm gonna get
my rook down here and check them again
and then put my rook to the side
embarrassing okay so you need a good
plan and that's the plan so you'll watch
it when I'm playing as the hero and it's
gonna be easy
yeah easy as it says okay all right so
let's see what I do first things first
you don't have to worry about checking
or anything you just get to work behind
the pawn right how easy can it be okay
so now he's setting up I discovered that
really doesn't work in this position too
well alright so h3 that stops whatever
so good [ __ ] so check the big check
alright so I'm out of it alright so rook
up not not a good place for that rook to
be that rook wants to be here or here
okay so when I push the pawn you can
never go there alright alright so
another check excellent right just help
my King get to where he wants to be
thank you alright so now it's like he's
got an idea he's gonna take my pawn but
it'll be too late if he does so I just
keep pushing and so now he's got to get
back there and a too late huh
so now black decides he's gonna try to
generate a passed pawn of his own while
white doesn't have to let me can just
play check King back pawn takes pawn
takes and now the King just comes and
there's nothing he can do so after a
pawn here how should he take yes
question yeah you just take and just
don't let them have any hope okay
or you could just play King to be
whatever but they're all good moves
another check
all right so now he doesn't even want a
tree he wants to have his rook and so
you get a queen and then you don't mess
around write a simple made into here
queen g8 checkmate
game over okay so see what see what he
did there he got an idea and he just
stuck to it huh
you know he didn't have to mess around
with all these shenanigans guys work
behind the pawn and then start get his
King going and start pushing that pawn
and everything's great yes the reason
why he played h3 I play h3 is so so he
wants to get this big discovered checker
right so let's say I just push my pawn
and he gets this check and then oh
because I was thinking like I just went
keep my options open so if he plays h3
oh yeah I don't think I was thinking
about checking them then I don't know I
don't know why play h3 but it's it's
fine I mean it's fun all right all right
so let's let's check out if my Stuart
can play a little bit better this time
okay and maybe he can actually get a win
all right so we even well hold up we'll
do this game first all right they're all
the same though okay look I even made it
easier for him okay I put the rook like
right behind the pawn like hey this is
where you want it okay so you really
shouldn't even make it any rook moves
this game okay but let's see if he does
anyway all right King up bring my F on
alright so now I got another idea
instead of bringing my King around a
stop I just I'm just gonna go and try to
get another pass pawn here anybody think
that's idea is good bad art hey let me
think about it for a minute
it's a bad idea
yeah but let's see if it ends up working
okay so his idea is easy I'm gonna bring
my pong up my king up and get a queen
I'm gonna get some pass pawns of my own
but then Jaden my student makes a move
that really hurt me okay I mean as a
teacher it makes me happy that he found
the move
well what move do you think is playing
this position working through how easy
yeah
all right and now it doesn't let me get
any kind of good counter play here all
right
so he's learning all right so that's
good all right so h6 oh I got it I got
to get a passport on takes pawn takes
check so more checks that have nothing
to do with nothing all right
so in this position what is the best
move again for white here well I assume
it's the best rook a to again yep all
right but he's losing time he's losing
valuable time by doing all this all
right what move if you were playing
white would you just slam right here
King Tubby seven right King b7 it
attacks it's it's yeah King b7 oh he
does know how does he mess it up then
all right all right so and I bring my
rook behind my passed pawn cuz that's
where I learned I want my Brooks behind
my passed pawns all right anybody have
any ideas what White's you play in this
position besides Wilson where's
everybody else just the song man Wilson
all right James IV pawn a7 yeah why stop
why stop it cuz if if blacks like oh oh
go get a queen yeah you just take the
pawn and then as Queen yes and it's very
simple Queen against rook you're gonna
win the rook that's what Kevin says and
I trust
so easy all right so all right so
instead he decides to play rook attacks
the pawn here and so now I got this
great idea I'm just gonna check white
forever and it's gonna be a draw like
check King up check King up well don't
go there King up check and draw right
but he tricks me I hate getting tricked
so so in this position after Rick f3 he
checks me any plays King to c8 and like
dude but instead of just checking again
like I wanted to
I think I'm playing great I'm gonna play
here and everything's just great
oh I lost more than just a pawn okay I
lost the whole game because I thought I
was so cool when I should have just been
checking all right so rook a 7 so what
does he do just to lose everything
yes Dan work so you like to be on the
side of the pot ok in this position it
doesn't matter if you go to the side to
the back wherever you want to be okay
it's all good as long as you protect the
pawn ok
all right so so let's see what he did in
that in that game that you know
successfully won the game ok so he had
the rook initially right behind this
pawn so we didn't have to even think
about that
and then hey just get a plan bring the
King March the King down you know
protect your pawn when need be and you
know so so he veered off course in this
position you know he should have just
stuck with his plan get the Queen
alright alright fair enough alright
let's let's see if he can play this one
like without any flaws at all oh yeah
big mistakes okay so it's white to move
again so basically you just have to do
the same thing so it's looking pretty
much the same like but I was like why I
had them at the end so I'm gonna try to
do the same thing as well alright so
this looking pretty similar so you guys
should next time you have an extra pawn
you should be like wow I know how to do
this I memorized two of these these end
games here so it's pretty easy so he
lets me have this pawn okay so he's like
I got so much time here so check now
does that have a move should we play
here hey seven right just push the pawn
how hard is it and so he's like I'm
gonna go get that spot and I'm like I'm
not gonna let you and now he's like oh
man well I got a better idea I just get
that pawn here and now he's got it
because he gets that pawn and there's
nothing he can do to promotion at the
end well because if you get a queen at
the end you got to assume your opponent
will take it so if you get a knight and
then he like oh oh I just get a pawn
here you got a lot of lot of chances for
a big night for their chances so you
never want to give up alright so so now
everybody should know you know how easy
it is you know when you have an extra
pawn here right all you have to do get
the rook behind the pawn bring the King
up and March the pawn
okay easy all right so so let's say you
have a dumb rook okay a dumb Rucker okay
your rook is in front of the pawn okay
so you know we are one square away from
queening here right but the rook is no
good so what should black do in this
position
yeah you better all think about all
right I'm going to give everybody three
options here well if I give one option I
know y'all jump at this option everybody
safe I broke a three Chuck it's awesome
okay wait I'm not going to let you two
have that as an option king f7 alright
King f7 you just lost the game you know
but you you want you were sabotaging all
along alright what is so bad about King
f7 you can don't get to say you don't
get to say what why it is bad
alright cuz they're playing against you
you're just ready to play black and you
decided to play King f7 the most dubious
move of all you want black um who lose
all right so why plate here and now
black plays king f7 you're like that
looks fine right but it's not fine
because rook h8 and if you take the pawn
rook takes check King moves rook takes
rook game over and then if you're like
oh man I want to just put my king there
or just go back to being a dumb rook no
plays a eight Queen protects the rook
rook takes the Queen rook takes and
game's over okay alright so so now we
know one move not to play and the other
move that's very similar to king f7 is
king f6 which is the ultimate blunder
because then you play rook F a check
King moves Queen white wins
all right so so Wilson's he's got all
the bad moves he's can tell me all the
bad moves in this position but I wonder
if you know whatever you can tell me a
good move rook a to excellent I like it
all right so King up now why did you got
Wilson take this pawn no you just move
your work back and forth back and forth
yeah the last thing you would do in this
position is take this pawn do you
understand why you look the g-eight
check King takes and then you got the
the easiest game or queen against the
rook so easy and yeah the rook yeah he's
gonna he's gonna die pretty soon all
right so so now you get some some ideas
so the last thing you want to do is ever
move your rook off of the the same line
as the pawn and you don't want to move
your king too far on the same rank as
the king and you definitely don't want
to move where it can just be a check and
not taken make sense to everybody so so
now we're just moving back and forth and
now we can start checking and checking
and checking until he's like oh I can't
take any of more these checks just let's
end the game okay because it's it's very
very annoying to get checked so much
okay so you see and the game is over all
right so so now you understand how to
play King upon n games so recap if
you're white and you have an extra pawn
at the end you want your rook behind the
pawn if you can't get them behind the
pawn get them to the side of the pond
and the last resort is a
the dumb Brook however with the dumb
rook you could do a lot of tricks and
trick a lot of opponents that are not so
good
all right so but that's it thank you for
coming to the end game class feel free
to hang out and play and try your best
with the UH with the extra pawn all
right thank you